oh
kevin
did we finish with 275 or are we waiting
okay because i see it for some reason
it's not on the work session schedule
it was recess that's why it's not thank
you
uh it is uh 1204 we were scheduled to
start at uh 11 30. uh technically i
think what we're doing was we're coming
out of recess from yesterday
um
i would like to start mr ripple let's go
ahead and start
with uh 430 that mclean amendment
[Music]
yes
okay so
um
i i
i had wanted to talk about this
amendment yesterday but i needed to talk
to the clerk to make sure i understood
when uh an amendment is germaine and
when it's not germaine and and and the
debate or the reason that's an important
uh distinction
is because if it's not germaine we've
got to schedule a separate hearing under
it
as it turns out
the clerk informs me that this this
amendment is germane
this is essentially intended to
authorize
uh
the the the additional words that would
be added to rsa 151 colon 2-f
the additional words would be that
unless the facility operates on a
membership basis model or exclusively
provides services to individuals
who make direct payment for services for
purposes of this paragraph a direct
payment is one that is paid directly by
the patient so so this is an attempt to
introduce a little bit more free market
flexibility into our health care system
this was uh uh
originally
house bill one zero
four
it passed the house
i don't have the vote of the of that
house vote but it did pass the house
it went over to the senate uh the senate
took it and decided to
interim study
at the request of representative mclean
who is the prime sponsor and
representative osborne
they're asking division three to
consider this for inclusion into 4 430
that that that's essentially the
background
um
is is there anyone here who can speak to
this bill mr williams are you prepared
or or could you tap dance or is there
anyone else that would be more qualified
chairman edwards thank you for the
record john williams the director of
legislative affairs for health human
services and the department was
monitoring the bill that you spoke of in
the senate that went to interim study we
did not provide testimony on that bill
and so i really don't have much more to
offer around that other than some of the
testimony as to why i was put into
interim study was general concerns
around access to health care and what
that could do relative to
a
facilities being able to allow to
operate outside of the specialty
healthcare licensure
by virtue of being a direct pay
entity and that's pretty much totality
what i think it can offer to the
committee i don't know if there's others
in the audience who would like to
provide you with information
do you do you recall any of the
testimony over on the house side that
my general recollection was uh the the
house obviously passed this and this was
the house position um are very close to
the house position do you recall uh
[Music]
so
i'm i'm thinking is is there anyone else
in the audience able to speak to this
bill thank you mr williams uh ms minahan
thank you representative paula minnehan
hospital association we did oppose this
bill in the in the house we opposed it
um last year when it was
introduced as well this is a little
different um
because mclean's bill actually was
combined um so 1044 was actually
combined with a membership-based
business model which was language that
came out of representative cushman's
bill and then it was combined and um
amended in the house i don't recall the
vote in the house committee to be honest
i think it probably was under um
probably party lines 11 to 10
or 12 to 10. um and greg moore from um
america's for prosperity supported the
bill and we strongly oppose it for the
reasons that representative excuse me
john williams um indicated um this could
impact access to services certainly for
our critical access hospitals was the
concern one of the concerns but it's
bypassing the requirement to all um
institut are all facilities to have a
charity care policy
um and that was a concern because that
means that you would not also not have
to
accept medicare or medicaid services
excuse me reimbursement so that's our
concern and it's um something that has
not been done anywhere else in the
country um this is i think modeled after
direct primary care which has some
some certainly legitimacy relative to
and that those are my terms
relative to direct services for
physicians
or practitioners providing care but this
would be facilities um with a direct
prime with direct
membership based and that was our
concern that is means that
hospitals are required to take all
comers and we don't understand how this
would work if if they have an emergency
room would they
refuse care of individuals
so that would be a concern to us as well
so i'm happy to share our testimony i
can i can email it to folks but we are
we strongly oppose the bill and um
um
so
that's our position is there anyone
would
stay there just second is there is
anyone here who can speak in favor of
this bill
cares to speak in favor of this bill
the way it was described to me is that
this is opposed by the hospitals because
um
it enables
additional competition to the hospitals
which is a cynical thing but i just
thought i'd put the cynical thing on the
table sure um we're not opposed to
competition we're opposed to
um
impeding access to care for the
vulnerable individuals and we believe
that this could have that effect
and we don't believe state state the
state should have a law that um supports
that position because
um they obviously support coverage for
individuals through medicaid and this
would bypass that so that's our that was
are there any other questions
uh representative weiler
i remember being in another's discussion
before
but the point
being made is the regular hospitals that
do provide emergency services etc
all have huge
discounts on property taxes and business
taxes and meals and rooms taxes that
amount to millions of dollars
and these
private type things would not
so that's one of the reasons since
that you're getting all the tax breaks
at the hospitals that's the reason why
because we're asking you to
provide
service
and quite often it's it's the board of
directors that decides how much but
anyway that's just what i've heard in
the past on these thank you
all right uh are there any other
questions
um i'm gonna call a five-minute recess
so that we can caucus on this
i didn't i didn't think we were going to
be able to do this today so some of the
prior prep hasn't been done
we're ready when you are but there's no
hurry if you're not done with your
discussion we can wait
okay
okay so we just completed uh less than
five minute recess i think so that we
could caucus on um
amendment 1742
um
and so is there a motion
i'm not sure the right motion is to make
but i'd move that we
include amendment 20221742h
to sb430
moved is that second and then seconded
um is there a discussion in your move so
effectively that's an otp on this as an
amendment to 430 that's what i'm hearing
i if this is the only amendment to 430
then i'd be moving otpa i guess i'm just
not sure if we're done with 430 at this
point
i don't know if we are but we can
move on this solitary amendment and then
if there are others we can do those also
they're not so i guess i'm moving to
recommend otpa on 430 with amendment
number 2022-1742h
all right is there a discussion
representative walner
well i'm i'm going to vote no on this
because
first of all it's the first thing first
time i've heard about it this morning
that we were going to uh try to include
it here
and
you know the senate does have it i
believe i
saw that they have an interim study
and it feels to me like this is
something that needs a little deeper
dive than i can do this morning
when i've only had like a
10 minute warning so
yes ma'am everything you just said is uh
absolutely correct
um i would i would just say that uh
if we uh do adopt this amendment uh
we're going to get another bite at the
apple at three o'clock tomorrow when the
full committee hears the
our recommendations so
it's it it's not quite over but every
every point you made is valid
and and i apologize for that i i just
couldn't
get a response from the clerk fast
enough to know whether or not i should
be sending this out to everyone and
getting you all excited about something
that may not be
even something we could consider
so um
with that
okay so although the uh testimony we
heard was opposed and negative to this
the way i read this is that we're
um
we're
trying to
establish
an alternative health care capability
that is membership based or relies on
the direct payment for services and what
we're saying is in order to encourage
and support an alternative health care
model
that what we're saying is that they
would not be
immediately
subject
to
the provision that's in law that they
have to provide services to all persons
so they
so they're just looking to be able to
service their members
and i think it's an interesting idea so
i'm gonna i'm gonna vote in favor but uh
is
if there is no other conversation uh mr
h
representative and if you're in favor
say yes if you're opposed say no
representative irf yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean
chairman edwards yes
mr chair the vote is four to three ah
thank you okay so now
we have to do an
administrative thing
in order for us to meet the clerk's
rules
this amendment
has to be
literally and precisely
all the way down to the comma identical
to what the house passed
and this version
um this amendment missed a comma
between
the phrase any person and starting in
the bold where it says unless the
facility is that is that accurate mr
ripple
yes it is so uh so i think we need a a
separate vote
to and i'm not sure how we would phrase
this but i would want to
allow you to go get that comma fixed
and that we would have we would have
already voted that we we want to approve
the version with the comma in there
yeah i think that's fine and if you want
to just do a show of hands on that vote
i think that would work okay so show of
hands if
uh
when mr ripple gets the comma inserted
in the appropriate place to make this
identical to hb one zero four four
um
do you
will you accept that amendment in lieu
of the version that we just debated
raise your hand
okay
if you're opposed to that please raise
okay so if you if you could take care of
that
do we have another 430 issue
you have three other amendments uh two
of which you requested yesterday and one
of which is new and a request of hhs so
i can take care of the ones you talked
about yesterday first if you'd like
let's do that well we've got 430 open
let's keep in it
and so the first one is to section three
the pilot program uh for developmental
disabilities you discussed a version of
this yesterday and the only change that
you requested was you wanted to make the
appropriation of 2.8 million lapsing and
so so two questions for you mr ripple um
which
amendment number does
1778 replace do you know i believe it
okay and then i was scanning this
skimming this looking for where we make
it so that the funds are lapsing and i'm
not just it's not jumping out well you
had um on page two in the appropriations
section roman seven you had language
specifically say stating that it would
not lapse and by removing that it would
lapse okay thank you for that
um
so we did discuss this yesterday um is
i would move that we
recommend
amendment number two zero two two one
seven seven eight h
two four thirty s four sb430
is there a second
seconded
not seeing any um
let's go let's go straight to a roll
call
or or should you tell me should we do a
raise of hands or or roll call roll
call's safer it's never wrong
right
oops
if you're in favor you'll say yes if
you're opposed you'll say no
representative earth yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean
representative walner
representative nordgren yes
representative long yes
chairman uh edwards yes
7-0
passes 7-0
okay um
so we're done with with that amendment
what what's the next one on the carousel
you talked yesterday
about deleting section six which is just
relative to a reporting requirement um
section 6 of the bill as it stands now
would remove the provisions saying that
this report shall be submitted annually
thereafter so you want to keep this as
an annual report so you would just
so amendment
1783 to
sb430
serves the purpose of keeping the
family planning services annual report
as an annual report rather than deleting
the requirement to
complete the report annually
so
i think we discussed this uh yesterday
do we have a motion
yes i would
move we recommend adoption of amendment
20221783h
to sp430 sure second
second
okay this it's now open for discussion
the discussion should be whether or not
you think we ought to continue to get
the family planning services annual
okay i
i would say not only should we but it
would be great if if somebody could send
me like just the pat most recent one
that was done uh because i i don't i
don't recall seeing it
and out of courtesy to um
hhs oversight chairman
pearson
if you if you could just send him a
courtesy copy as well
okay so thank you mr williams
um
is there any further discussion or did
we just vote on we just voted on this
right seven nothing
oh okay
okay um
i i want to do
the roll call just because
i i don't remember exactly what the deal
was but i got ourselves uh off step by
taking uh hand votes when they wanted a
documented roll call so i just don't
want to with the
there is no time for a mistake at this
point so
so the motion is to adopt
amendment 1783 for senate bill 430. if
you're in favor you'll say yes i've
opposed no
representative earth yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean
representative walner
representative nordgren
representative long yes
chairman edwards yes
7-0
thank you
we have one more on 4 30. you have one
more um
i'll hand this out this is a department
request it amends section 29 of the bill
and section 29
removes a reference to the anna phil
brook center and this will replace it
with a reference to hampstead hospital
did did we discuss it at all yesterday
all right so this is this is a little
bit of a surprise but as far as
so
i have a question for you mr williams
about this
and and my question is
um are we getting over our skis a little
bit
siding hampstead hospital when as i
understand it that deal is not
uh chairman edwards for the record john
williams legislative uh director for the
department of health and services and
with me is uh joe curisti chief
financial officer for new hampshire
hospital
and uh chairman edward thank you very
much for preparing this amendment at the
request of the department we are
actually on on going through the process
right now to identify contracting
for
certain rate settings with commercial
private insurers very much like we do
under the current statute current law as
it relates to new hampshire hospital and
glencliff home so this is really a belt
and suspenders amendment that's being
requested by the department because the
bill currently has provision where the
in philbrook center no longer is
utilized for children's behavioral
health services and it already has a
catch-all for other entities that are in
the state mental health system but our
wonderful general legal counsel frank
nachman identified the potential for a
belt and suspenders request
that where the anaphil berk has been
struck we are moving into negotiations
uh contracting around rate setting with
the commercial private insurers um that
we just want to make sure that we
include hampstead hospital specifically
as an entity in addition to that mr
christie who's with me here today also
identified because we're just looking at
this one specific statute to making a
change uh to that because this is that
statute that deals with the contracting
authority that uh mr christie identified
that we want to limit the scope of our
universe to the state-owned uh
facilities so that's the only change
that we're requesting for this
particular section and these
conversations are going on as we speak i
understand so i'm gonna have mr christie
please either add or correct anything i
might have mistakes so in an interesting
time let me let me just say back what i
think i heard you say and then mr
christie can uh uh you know extend or
revise my remarks okay what i what i
think i heard is that we're doing the
obvious thing we're getting we're taking
the and phil brook center out because
we're no longer negotiating rates for
them and although we don't yet
uh have the hampstead hospital in our
constellation of state-owned facilities
where they're nevertheless trying to get
ahead of the curve and doing the rate
negotiation now
and we don't actually have any current
authority to do those contract
negotiations unless we pass this bill is
is that is that fair
that is correct
okay so
um do you have anything else you'd like
to say about this
no thank you for your consideration all
right thank you uh do i have a motion
uh yes i move we recommend adopting
amendment number two zero two two dash
one seven zero one h two s p four thirty
is there a second
representing bean seconds is there any
discussion
i guess i should have asked this of john
williams but
if we didn't include
hampstead hospital
what what problems would that
could have what what are the problems
that could occur if you don't mind that
i asked them i no i think that's fine
once you come on up i i i'm going to try
to guess the lawyer part and just say
that uh we don't have the authority to
negotiate commercial rates uh
until we own the facility and this
allows that commercial rate negotiation
to go by in a binding way
is that close
that is um accurate that is from frank
nachman who's our chief legal counsel
from the department who confirmed that
we do need to have this legislative
change
for being able to do what we otherwise
were able to do with the anna feldberg
center and mr christie anything else ad
i i would just add that this um
the notion of our general counsel uh
thinking of this actually came from us
working on trying to negotiate rates for
hampstead hospital
glad to have a follow-up so the the
words in here that say other state-owned
facilities
respectfully i i believe that it does
however belts and suspenders being what
it is and our chief legal counsel did
make the request for us to proceed to
further clarifying that uh the hampstead
hospital could be included in the
legislation on only this specific
section you'll see throughout uh senate
bill uh central 430 there are other
references for cleanup that we're not
touching today that just used the
broader language moving forward
so mr williams follow up on that
today or today
hampstead hospital is not
a state-owned facility is that
correct or wrong
that is correct
okay so today if we want to negotiate
commercial rates
we have to specifically include them in
the language otherwise they would not be
included is that
yes i think that's a fair assessment
okay okay so based on that
should we put a separate sub
effective date for this paragraph
or or does 430 just say upon signature
of the governor anyways
i would defer to mr ripple just that's a
great question uh what the effective
date is for section 29 i think this
might have been one upon passage but i
just don't have the effective dates in
front of me and similarly is there any
wisdom or any legal ability for us to
retroactively make this effective as of
you know a month or two ago because the
negotiation started a month or two ago i
suspect
is you're nodding your head mr christie
is that does that make sense to try to
make it retroactive if that's legal
i think that would make sense we
certainly started these conversations
over the past six weeks or so so what if
we could make it retroactive what date
i think april first would be fine
april fool's my favorite uh mr ripple um
so it is currently effective upon
passage and i'm not sure i've ever seen
a retroactive effective date before on a
bill so i'm not sure that that's
something you would want to attempt
more of that crazy out of the box
thinking so uh so i'll leave that alone
and assume that the people negotiating
want the negotiations to be binding
anyway so we don't need the extra
detail
okay
all right
uh were we still in discussion do you
have more follow-up go ahead one one
more one more question so if the deal
what does this have any would this have
any um
obligation for the state if we had
included it here and the deal fell
through
go ahead take a job
i don't believe so um i think if the
deal were to fall through the state
would have no
authority to set rates for dams or for
hampstead hospital or real no purpose to
do so
are there any other questions
not not seeing any i think we've
completed the discussion and we're ready
mr clerk could you conduct a roll call
vote on 1701 please
the motion is to adopt amendment 1701
for senate bill 430. in favor say yes
oppose say no representative irv yes
represent weiler votes yes
representative bean
representative walner
representative nordgren
representative long yes chairman edwards
yes
mr chairman of the voters 7-0
uh thank you so that wraps up 430 i
understand yup that's all you had except
um so do we need to do an otpa on 430
with the amendments and and that the one
that's awaiting the comma yes
so i will move
we recommend adoption
when has changed have a comma
all those amendments to
otpa with those amendments on
sp
430.
is there a second
seconded by representative bean
um
so is there any discussion on
otpa
motion
not not seeing any
the motion is on octopass as amended by
all those uh four
mentioned amendments
if you're in favor you'll say yes if
you're opposed you'll say no
representative irf yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean yes
representative
walner
reluctantly yes
representative nordgren
yes
representative long yes
chairman edwards enthusiastically yes
uh thank you so with that we finished up
on uh 4 30 uh for today um
we probably need to write a blurb on
this
is there is there a requirement for a
blurb well there is right
yes
any anyone enthusiastic about writing
now we'll find somebody
we will have to describe what each
separate amendment did
just the amendments not the whole bill
is is that the case no you will say you
know the committee voted in favor and
you describe what the bill does and then
say that this amendment changes this
this all right change that you'll write
that yeah
representative will uh write that
uh did you have a question i do have a
question
so tomorrow when we um come to this bill
there will be and that one opera there
will be another opportunity to amend it
i i will make sure that in particular
you have an opportunity to talk through
the membership based amendment do you
want to talk to all of them or
specifically to that one no just that
one so i i will i will make sure that uh
we we take a fresh look in the full
committee on that okay i want to think
through what the process is though to
exclu to get that out of the bill let's
say that's what i want to do is to take
you won't because the motion tomorrow
would be ought to pass as amended and
you would take separate votes on each
amendment uh so you would have it again
okay tomorrow so we can just vote no on
that amendment right tomorrow
right right
thank you no problem and to tie it into
a side conversation you may have heard
snippets of
it
it had been recommended to me to try to
make this the form of a a trailer bill
format so that we could
add and subtract particular clauses
without having to redo the whole thing
and as mr ripple has
educated me it's effectively already
that way because we're handling these
amendments separately is that correct
okay i'm representing weiler
could i ask mr ripple
is it five total amendments
four amendments
okay
all right which one am i mistaken on
1778 1783
1701 yeah
and 1742 with the addition of a comma
i had it down twice thank you
such a good it was such a good amendment
do it twice
okay uh i think i think we're done
discussing 430 um
so so let's go
mr ripple as i recall the amendment we
were going to ask
was
on line eight
the
term and non-public
was was added
and it looks like we added at the bottom
on line 19 into 20
the governor may remove any
non-legislative member with or without
cause that's that's what you requested
yep and i do have that amendment yeah
and and i think i for some reason i
think i already have it uh but is it uh
one seven seven five
it is and you know i think i handed it
out at the end of the day yesterday so i
have spare copies if anybody needs one
okay and then we also
does the amendment technically added a
paragraph w
because there's a v and then a w is
that's just like a little renumbering
thing
w
275.
okay so in summary we're going to uh
pull up an amendment to sb 275 that was
uh partially discussed yesterday the
part that we discussed was the inclusion
of the phrase and non-public to
expand upon the idea that this support
is intended for public
school programs and also the non-public
ones
the part that we did not discuss i don't
believe
is the last sentence that says the
governor may remove any non-legislative
member with or without cause
um
that seems to me to make sense because
if if anyone gets arrested for
something horrible
it may be necessary for the good of the
reputation of the advisory commission to
be able to remove an individual
such as that
uh you know for example if somebody got
arrested you know dealing opioids it
would be good to get them off of the
opioid commission
um
so uh so that that's the general purpose
so so we can take a motion and if
there's a second we can discuss it
further
i would move
uh amendment number 2022-1775h
to
that we recommend that amendment to it
is there a second
seconded by representative bean
discussion
i'm just going to specifically ask you
what's your reaction to the addition of
the power of the governor to remove a
commission member
i i think i'm fine if you said with
cause
but the without cause
is concerning to me because it seems
like that could get very political
sure sure i didn't mean it to be
political i just meant that i i wanted
if the governor were to do it i didn't
want to have to evolve involve some
legal
process
to show cause um that that's why i did
that but if you'd be happier with the
striking or without
uh i i don't i don't have a real concern
about it i was just trying to make sure
we didn't end up in a big hr protracted
well i mean i just saw this but what
strikes me about it is the without cause
um i mean with cause if someone is
picked up for dwi
or
using drugs or something i guess that
would be cause i don't know who
determines what causes either it it
would be the governor
you know that's that's why it would be
flexible um
without question really bothers me
because it seems like that could turn
into a political thing is it is there
any other thought on that
yeah yeah you agree representative
nordgren how about you representative
i also agree i i believe there's already
cause if somebody's sitting on a drug
task force and they get arrested for
dealing drugs i i think there's already
a
uh policy with which they could
be put off that so yeah i would agree
with the uh removing without with cost
you're okay with cause right okay
so uh any other discussion on on that i
i i'm open to
deleting or without
um
just you know because i
hopefully it'll never happen to begin
with but uh
but i just don't want anyone to think
man ask me a question uh yes go ahead
representative can we do that without
getting another rewritten amendment or
you could you could adopt the amendment
all right
remove my i mean withdraw my my motion
and make a new one
just keep it clean yes sir
so i would move
adoption of amendment number two zero
two two dash one seven seven five h to
sp 275
with the removal of the words with or
with without cause at the end of the
piece amending section seven
but we i think we intend to keep the the
words worth calling sorry thank you or
with excuse me
rewording those last few words
removal of or without cause
no no remove or without
just with cause
so we're leaving with cause
sorry yes no sir no sweat okay so um is
there a second to that modified
amendment or a motion
okay
deleting
deleting simply without
or without the two words or or without
cause
from amendment one seven seven five
cause is not being deleted
just oh just the words or without well
it reads
okay
so it'll still read with cause
with okay just without
deleting without or leading with the
words or and without i'm glad you had
the same issues as i did representative
thank you for making me look not so bad
all right if you're in favor of that
adopting that emotion with the change
still stated please say yes
if you're opposed say no
representative earth yes
weiler votes yes bean yes uh represent
walnut
represent nordman yes representative
long yes
chairman edwards uh yes
seven to zero seven to nothing uh that
amendment to 470 or 275 passes
um
mr ripple we don't have any other
amendments to consider on 275 right no
you don't
so so do we need a motion now on otpa on
275 yes
uh is there such a motion so moved
it's moved
seconded
mr clark when you're ready
okay so the only amendment is the
okay the motion is ought to pass as
amended by
amendment one seven seven five with the
if you're in favor you'll say yes you're
opposed you'll say no
representative earth yes representative
votes yes representative bean
representative
walner yes
representative nordgren yes
representative long yes
chairman edwards yes
mr chair of the voters 7-0 7-0 uh
recommendation to finance will be
otpa on sb275
uh is there anyone interested in writing
yes representative irf says yes
okay thank you
which takes us to 416.
i i think there's an amendment there
that you've not yet passed out that's
so yesterday you considered an amendment
to remove section 3 entirely
and
you ultimately decided to ask for
another amendment to leave section 3 in
place but add the words
if a functional behavioral assessment
exists for the student so that's the
which bill are we doing now
okay just just to
i guess restate
what
mr ripple just said
does something very narrow
it seems to comply with the intent that
we heard in testimony yesterday that
they aren't looking to create a new
requirement
for a functional behavioral assessment
if there isn't one when it's time to be
considered
so so
by not making it
a new requirement
we dealt with the financial aspect
i had been concerned going into it if we
were creating an unfunded mandate and so
that
easily took care of my concern
so um so that's that's all i think this
amendment does
um
is there
emotion
i would
excuse me i would move that we adopt or
that the committee adopt
uh amendment of
2022-1786-h to
sb 416.
excuse me again what you say the
amendment does uh
but what it does yeah it okay it's just
sprays here if a behavioral assessment
exists for the student
and
and the reason this was important
is because yeah otherwise it's it read
like everyone would have to do one for
every piece of
okay
okay so is there a second to the motion
representative bean
seconds
i'm not seeing any discussion um
so
[Music]
you got so much writing to do there mr
clerk so but when you're ready we'll be
patient when you're ready we'll we can
do a roll call on this
um you know let's because we're going to
have to do roll call on the otpa let's
just do a show of hands on this
amendment
there we go so show of hands if you
approve of this amendment that looks to
be seven to nothing
so so now i need a mo
now i need a motion on ot
i would move otpa
with that amendment i would move we
recommend otpa with amendment number two
zero two two dash one seven eight six h
on to sb four one six is that second i'm
sorry before you take that vote could i
just mention one thing i just want i
wanna make sure
it it comes up so the other issue that
you discussed yesterday was the
possibility of a state cost
and i emailed you all
an email provided by rebecca ross of the
department that showed a state cost of
725 000 in fiscal 24 and 1.5 1.4 million
and 25 so i just wanted to make sure you
all had that and were aware of it before
you voted on the bill
all right give me those figures again
you have a copy of the email can can we
just share a copy of the email because
i'll get them in the record okay
uh 725 000 in fiscal 24
and 1.4 million in fiscal 25.
i think we have a motion and a second
and so is there any further discussion
if if anyone would like to discuss the
the numbers that mr ripple just shared
i i have a question for for you mr
ripple or maybe somebody in the crowd
by inserting the phrase if a functional
behavioral assessment exists for the
student
it's not requiring a new one to be done
so i'm just wondering
where the these what the what's driving
these costs
i think that amendment addresses any
potential local cost however there's a
state cost created by sections one and
two and i think uh
miss ross would be better
better situated to answer that than i
would okay so we're we're talking about
the body the bill again not the
amendment
okay is ross do you do you want to
remind us of what you probably said
yesterday
members of the committee rebecca ross
the director of the bureau for
children's behavioral health when we
discussed this yesterday we talked about
the amendment resolving any question
that there would be additional costs
through the educational system in the
local school districts
but the the body of the bill requires
that if an fba has not been done in the
school context and there is one needed
for a youth who's at risk of residential
placement
either through the bureau of children's
behavioral health or dcyf that dhhs
would be responsible for
obtaining that fba and in order to do
that
we came up with these numbers for the
six months from january 1 in 2024 and a
full year
in the second year and 25.
okay i know you did this yesterday but
would you remind us
this is the cost of doing an fba would
you would you just uh
trip through a couple of benefits and
what the financial implication may be of
the benefits of having an fba available
sure the the
if an individual is going into
residential treatment as a result of the
their behavior in at home or in the
community and an fba can be used to
address and come up with a plan for
those behavioral challenges the goal
would be to reduce or eliminate the need
for residential treatment including
out-of-state residential treatment
the goal of doing it when they are at
risk of going into residential would be
doing it earlier so that we're not
waiting to treat them in a residential
setting so by spending 10 to 15 hours at
approximately 400 an hour to have the
appropriate professional do the
functional behavioral assessment and
have a corresponding treatment plan that
works with all of the other elements of
the system of care
including the cans assessment and the
cat tool for
determining the appropriate level of
residential treatment we would then take
that information
to meet the child's treatment needs and
reduce the need for expensive care
either residentially or out of state
so um i have a follow-up for you
and and this and this is probably
i'm kind of used to seeing cost-benefit
analysis and and i'm seeing the cost
analysis
a benefit analysis would inform us
whether or not it would be possible to
actually reduce our net costs because
as a benefit to having the information
so i'm just curious in your professional
opinion do you think this is
incremental cost addition or do you
think once we
factor in the benefit of having this
information earlier that we may actually
avoid costs and end up in a
a you know financially a positive
situation
i think this combined with the other
initiatives of the children's system of
care we will absolutely
see
over time a reduction in the higher
expenditures which will overall reduce
costs i think that we won't see that
until we we have it in place and have it
incorporated into the residential and
community based treatment programs so
initially there will be that added cost
the five to ten year will certainly this
will contribute to decreases in costs of
residential and long-term care
so so what i would appreciate you
thinking about is if i get invited back
next year to have anything to do with
dhhs budgeting i if you could make sure
to remind us
if you have more better information
about the cost-benefit side of this i i
just would like to hear it as an update
absolutely i think what is difficult is
with all of the changes that we're
making to reflect the outcome from one
particular change it's more of the
system-wide change and this is a key
piece of that i totally believe you uh
are there uh representative walner
yes uh from a question for miss ross um
does this also include children in the
juvenile justice system
yes absolutely so all children who were
going into residential treatment
or at risk of now we've we've taken out
of the numbers those that have an autism
spectrum diagnosis that would be covered
with by medicaid those that had already
had one through the schools so we've
tried to narrow it down to those who
anywhere in this system would be
accessing residential but don't
otherwise have one provided for them
great thank you
um
and we have we we have a motion in a
second on an otpa i believe um
so uh when you're thank you miss ross
thank you uh mr clerk when you're ready
uh would you take a roll
question is on ought to pass as amended
amendment number 1786 for senate bill
416. if you're in favor you'll say yes
if you're opposed you'll say no
representative irv yes representative
weiler votes yes representative bean
yeah
representative walner
yes
representative nordgren yes
representative long yes
chairman edwards yes
7-0
okay so
so i think we've uh completed action on
sb 416 is that correct
that's
uh do we have anyone wanting to write
the committee report uh representative
walner
thank you
and then all these reports were
i i
i think the real answer is it should be
done before three o'clock tomorrow but
the sooners the better
um
we did 4 30 we did 4 44 yesterday
we did um 4 58 yesterday
that brings us down to our last item of
business which is uh sb 459 mr ripple
did we get the amendment
no um and i'm not sure when it will be
back i do expect it back today but i
didn't leave it with ols until around 11
o'clock and i think it might take them
what what is on the calendar for
tomorrow morning for finance i i know
that uh representative umberger doesn't
but i i don't have situational awareness
on the rest of the finance movements
tomorrow
there's no other finance
meetings scheduled until the three
o'clock
but if you did a recess and announce it
now to a time certain that would be
legal
to continue this the people that are
interested are here now as are the
people that might want to testify
and uh i'll ask
janet to put a note outside the door
and we could probably meet here at 11 or
something like that so so let's discuss
this uh it it it
we have to come in tomorrow anyways
uh representative long are you are you
gonna be there for the finance meeting
tomorrow anyway so
i don't believe
for three o'clock i was i'd yeah i
didn't know about that but yeah i guess
at three i believe i am
we might
how long is it going to take you might
want to meet at 2 30 here so so this
this is what i'm thinking
um
there's there's a lot of words i think
in 259 that we the amen or the amendment
to 459 has a lot of words in it it's got
probably
five or six different concepts in it uh
to me that is not a 30-minute
conversation that feels to me to be
longer
what do you think miss ripple
it could be longer for sure um i think
everything that's in the amendment was
talked about yesterday however seeing it
with fresh eyes might uh encourage more
conversation
okay so we we could get through it in 30
minutes it could take 90 minutes
so so so what i'm thinking go ahead
represent i just we um we had scheduled
a caucus
for all the finance democrats at two
o'clock
before the three o'clock meeting so if
we could just avoid that because then
i've got to change everybody yes ma'am
so so here's my proposal
i propose
we start at 11
and then if we finish early then we can
have a nice relaxing lunch and you can
you can saunter into the
caucus
um and and if it happens to go long
we have some time to handle it and have
a complete conversation and we'd still
be done by two with probably time to
grab a quick launch
representative nordgren
i can't hear you
uh no it seems like that's allotting a
lot of time i'm not sure we need to
okay i would in deference to your
experience with these things um would a
noon start be okay with you
maybe we could maybe grab a lunch before
we get started and
and that way we'd try to for sure be
done by two so that you could hit your
caucus i don't anticipate it's gonna
yeah you could you we could just take a
straw poll now and really get it done
yeah
okay we have to see it so um i
what's your recommendation
what about 12 30 let's put the
difference yeah
yeah
uh all right so
um
i will uh ask mr ripple that that when
you do get the copy of the amendment
that you just email it to the whole
committee as soon as you get it and then
we will recess this
until 12 30 tomorrow
[Music]
we are now in
well let me do one more check
so we have people in the audience who
were concerned about 459.
how how i i i'm sorry that we're not
ready to do this today
um
but we're not so um
uh i would like to make sure that anyone
who's interested in getting a copy of
the amendment
the get gets one really quickly so if
you will give your email address to mr
ripple we'll just try to get you a quick
copy you know immediately after the
committee gets one
and then we'll meet tomorrow at 12 30.
is that acceptable
okay uh we are on recess until
12 30 tomorrow uh in this room uh to
recess on sb 459 with the amendment
that's coming
and be sure and tell janet to post it
i got a question i gotta ask somebody
here
hmm
sorry harry well you got to come in
anyways tomorrow so it's not like a new
okay
children and family law version as
passed by the house we would doubt any
changes
and it was a six to one vote
i felt the
the voltage and
that
we
walked away from
some republican good government
principles being advocated our
responsibilities public safety
but uh
all right i'll i'll i'll swing by
i think i'm done for the day i gotta
check
okay
hmm
training
you